منازل متراصه
وازقه ضيقه وكثافه سكانيه مرتفعه
هي حال المخيمات في غزه زادتها سوءا حراره
الصيف وانقطاع الكهرباء لساعه طويله
التفاصيل في منزل الحجه ام ماجد بمخيم
الشاطئ بسيطه للغايه لكن الحياه صارت اكثر
صعوبه بدنا نخزننا نبفت حاجه في الثلاجه
بدنا نطلع بدنا
نغسلنا حاجب بدنا نعيش على الهوايه هذا
احنا قاعدين في كهرباء احنا العرق
مع ارتفاع درجات الحراره يزداد استخدام
الكهرباء
لكن وصل التيار الكهربائي لا يزيد على 6
ساعات في اليوم عجز اثار غضب السكان الذين
يطالبون بضروره ايجاد حلول جذريه يتعمل
الاحتلال المسؤوليه الكامله عما يحدث
ومتعلق بالتيار الكهربائي في قطاع غزه
بالاضافه الى ضروره ان تتعمل حركه حماس
مسؤولياتها في التوزيع العادي لموضوع
الكهرباء
حلول يقول المسؤولون هنا ان الظروف
السياسيه والاحتلال الاسرائيلي يقفان في
وجه كثير منها نعمل جاهدين على انه نطور
مصادر الطاقه الموجوده لدينا من خلال
وسائل عديده الطاقه المتجدده او
خط الغاز الذي ان شاء الله يكتمل ويرى
النور
تاثير انقطاع التيار الكهربائي شمل مناحي
الحياه كافه سواء في الشوارع العامه او في
المستشفيات وفيما اغلقت مصانع اضطرت
بلديات الى ضخ مياه الصرف الصحي في البحر
دون معالجه مع انقطاع المياه عن اجزاء
واسعه من القطع يبقى بحر غزه
الحر داخل المنازل التي يشبهها اصحابها
بالافران ازمه انقطاع الكهرباء بهذا جاءت
لتراكم جمله الازمات التي تعصف بالقطاع مع
استمرار الحصار الاسرائيلي وجمود الاوضاع
السياسيه الفلسطينيه هشام زقوط الجزيره
غزه فلسطين